wie war es also die alte männer frage
dann daher vielleicht besser als ich das
ist auch etwas was hier bei banken in
diesem stück ein grundthema ist so diese
vorstellung von männlichkeit da gibt es
da einen der besser im bett ist als ich
wann hast du ihn zum letzten mal gesehen
erzähler ein bisschen vom letzten mal
wenn ich ihn das letzte mal gesehen habe
das war derselbe tag indem er abreiste
das steht mir so lebhaft vor augen
ich erinnere mich
ich saß da und erzählt ihm eine blöde
geschichte aus dem hotel in dem ich
lebte ich saß da lacht du sagst da und
lacht ist ja ich saß da und dachte doch
dann traf mich plötzlich seine augen ein
paar erstaunte zornige augen doch einmal
wie ein blitz traf es mich dass dies
doch das letzte mal war das letzte mal
ja ich fühlte in diesem augenblick so so
sicher so seltsam sicher dass ich ihn
niemals wiedersehen sollte niemals im
gut und was gelitten nicht wahr
wie kommst du darauf soll es unser
ganzes leben kaputt machen dass ein
anderer mann mich besessen vor dir
wir befinden uns am lietzensee park in
berlin charlottenburg wo wir heute mit
der kulturjournalistin manuela reichert
über das stück der stärkere von daten
sprechen werden
und sie wird uns darüber berichten warum
das stück wieder entdeckt und wieder
aufgeführt werden sollte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich finde es unglaublich faszinierend
diesen zweiakter es ist von einer großen
intensität wie diese beiden menschen und
dann tritt eben irgendwann der dritte
auf nämlich diese frühe dieser frühere
liebhaber wie die miteinander umgehen
wie das ein wortgefecht ist in dem es um
die frage geht was ist liebe was es
eifersucht und kann das nicht was
unglaublich zerstörerische sein ich
finde das wirklich spannend also wir
haben es ja mit einem stück zu tun
jahrhundertwende von dass jäger und die
frau in diesem stück ist eine sehr
eigenständige sehr selbstständige person
die handelt die kein opfer ist
gleichzeitig natürlich aber mit unseren
vorstellungen von der situation von
frauen bewegung gar nichts zu tun hat
aber sozusagen eine superserie kraft in
diesem stück ist eine weibliche
subversive kraft die mit einer großen
entschiedenheit auf gefühl selbst und
das ist in all diesen stücken von daten
so dass diese frauen sehr sehr besonders
sind
die erste deutschsprachige übersetzung
der werke von dagny tool hat lars brandt
vorgelegt der sohn von willy brandt und
diese werksammlung wurde erstmals 2009
10 auf der frankfurter buchmesse als
norwegen das partnerland war präsentiert
wir sprechen jetzt mit ihm weil die
biografie der autorin der stärkere ist
nur vordergründig betrachtet ein simples
stück drei personen keiner außenwelt
kaum handlung in wirklichkeit geht es um
die undurchdringbar kite dessen was in
der seele sich abspielt um das geheimnis
zwischen männern und frauen um das
dunkle dickicht im zentrum unseres
daseins
wenn man so will ein hardcore
seelendrama dargeboten in einer
laborsituation
verwunderlich genug dass du mich nie
vergessen konntest du hast mich
geschlagen einfach geschlagen
wie du dich danach sehen ist wieder
meinen fuß in deinem nacken zu spüren
seine augen sind übrigens solltest du
wirklich mit mir kommen
das ist genau das richtige leben für
dich immer was neues neue orte seltsame
leute ich werde dir abenteuer bieten von
denen du nie geträumt hast und ich werde
dich zwingend zu vergessen was alles
böse ist
doch offen gesagt ich möchte ja nicht
unhöflich sein
du hast genug von mir für diesen tag gut
ich gehe aber ich komme wieder
ich komme bald wieder und dann musst du
darauf vorbereitet sein dass du mit mir
gehen wirst
ich gebe niemals auf du bist nun einmal
die die ich besitzen werde nicht mit dir
nie im leben gehabt du kannst nicht
zwingen
du sollst nicht wiederkommen ich will es
nicht
statt mich nicht so an
wie jetzt
g
[Musik]
daher bringt da etwas ganz neues ins
spiel
sie selbst ist eine emanzipierte absolut
und bürgerliche frau die weiblichen
gestalten die sie auf die bühne stellt
sind wird sich wenig überraschend sind
nicht brav aber sie sind eben auch nicht
gut sondern böse das stück ist vor über
100 jahren geschrieben weist aber weit
hinaus in bereiche komplizierte
verschlungene seelische problemfelder
die eigentlich erst viel später magath
wurden sozusagen es ragt aus der
vergangenheit in die zukunft
wenn daniel zwerg steht die macht der
leidenschaft die amoralität der gefühle
im zentrum die sich durchsetzen ohne
rücksicht auf die folgen teilweise
grausam eine grausamkeit die ihr reales
echo findet im leben der autorin die
schon mit anfang dreißig ermordet wurde
von einem schafskopf aus dem tross ihres
mannes der sie offenbar schon länger
loswerden wollte auf einer reise im
hotelzimmer von hinten erschossen
man könnte sagen das neunzehnte
jahrhundert schlägt blutig zurück
[Musik]
ich finde das ist ein äußerst
merkwürdiges bild sonst langweilen mich
die meisten bilder ja er dieses aber hat
eine unheimliche stimmung sich gar nicht
davon loskommen kann
an eine sache habe ich oft gedacht dich
ja bei dir wichtig danach fragen wollen
lieber frage worum handelt es sich also
damals als wir uns kennenlernten
warst du da eigentlich verlobt mit ihm
das ist im grunde schon etwas daraus
gemacht dass wir beide zusammen war oder
nicht nein eigentlich nicht
weißt du selbst gehalten hatte das sagt
mir gut glaubst du ganz im ernst dass
ich mir nichts - die machen antwortete
mir ehrlich glaubst du das glauben
glaube gott gerne gebe ich mein leben
dafür glauben zu können dass sich die
ein zehntel von dem bedeutet was du mir
bedeutet könnte ich einen tag eine
stunde das sichere gefühl haben was du
meinen bist wenn du mich wirklich liebt
es dann da müsstest du mir doch für eine
sekunde deine seele öffnen denn kleid
ist mir ich bekomme ich nicht zu fassen
nicht einen augenblick habe ich dich
ganz du du schließt mich auszugeben was
ist denn nicht dass meine seele besitzt
du nicht
warum willst du mich leiden sehen
ich will dich nicht quälen ich kann es
auch nicht ertragen nicht leiden zu
sehen
du bist der einzige der gut ist der
einzige den ich liebe kannst du mir das
nicht glauben
zum einen würde ich sagen dass wir in
einer situation monströser vereinfachung
sucht leben und das werk ist geeignet
könnte geeignet sein
dem etwas entgegenzusetzen im ganzen hat
sich die auseinandersetzung mit seiner
jüdisch glaube ich sehr in grenzen
gehalten soweit ich das weiß
und auch in norwegen ist erst vor 25
jahren ein band erschienen mit ihren
gesammelten werken so dass ich
eigentlich die wirkung ihres schaffens
erst jetzt richtig entfalten kann
[Musik]